I'm curious whether I should be taking iron is the next question.
So whether a person should be taking iron or not, really depends on their complete
blood count.
So their CBC part of their blood test is how you would determine whether a person should
be taking iron or not.
So there are several different types of anemia.
One type of anemia is anemia where you have deficiency, iron deficiency, anemia.
And those people can be taking iron.
Now, you have to take other things into consideration as well.
If on your CBC, you should have also requested on your CBC that you also tested for ferritid.
Now, ferritid is low, that can be a sign of deficiency as well.
You would not treat the ferritid low if your red blood cells were within normal limits.
But if your red blood cells are low, your R-E-W is high and other signs of higher deficiency
are there.
But if your ferritid is elevated, then you don't give iron.
So you have to treat it some other way, but you don't want to give iron if you have elevated
ferritid.
You know you have an inflammatory process going on and you have to dig too bad.
However, just because you have anemia doesn't mean that you should go in even if it's
iron deficiency anemia, doesn't mean you should go and treat it with iron.
Like anything, you need to dig to find out why do I have anemia.
So are you bleeding?
Maybe it's just excess blood from you have heavy periods.
Well, you need to dig to why that is and solve that.
You don't just treat things with supplements, nor should you just treat things with medication
without figuring out why in solving that answer to that why first.
However, if you come to that decision and you're going to use iron, then you have to look
at all those other factors.
Also, if you do have cancer, taking iron is an issue, can be an issue too because iron can
be gobbled up by cancer.
Because there is another type of anemia called anemia, chronic disease, where stage 4 cancer
patients will end up showing anemia, and then you want to couple anemia with artimisticid
as well.
So if the cancer is going to couple the iron intake with artimisticid as well, because if the
cancer is going to gobbled up the iron, you may try to, artimisticid is an arm that tends
to go carried, be carried with iron, and it can be carried into the cancer cell to help
kill it.
So that could be beneficial.